[Music]  really impossible  what is updates basically licking a  bubble yeah like a bubble what's the  sentence you thought you'll ever see  [Music]  intense music plays hit me with it  [Music]  that pineapple lime lemon yes look at  this looks like I'm the what the commune  of truck that isn't that great you  scraped oh yeah  Apple sherry it's apple juice that you  can really build it looks like blood  though it's a beat do you like medicine  but kinda looks like puke maybe it's a  smoothie chocolate chip cookie no its  tail what backstage ask about a bubble  [Music]  he said it's like lettuce but it's  different  [Music]  it's cool that you can mix flavors into  bubbles these are awesome I'm definitely  doing this when I get home when life  gives you lemons this mixed up with  bubbles  [Music]